[Música]
economía en france 24 ya me acompañará
el estudio jorge hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches analizamos entonces el
impacto que tiene la reducción en el
bombeo del gas ruso hacia europa cuando
pues como lo sabemos el invierno está
prácticamente a la puerta de la esquina
en el hemisferio norte santiago y es que
después de 10 días de este mantenimiento
en el north stream uno que conecta al
gas ruso con europa ese viejo continente
todavía va a tener que estar luchando
para tratar de calentar los hogares y
sobre todo mantener viva la industria en
el invierno que se aproxima antes de las
reparaciones las entregas ya habían
disminuido un 60 por ciento y ahora
rondan el 40 por ciento occidente acusa
a rusia de usar la energía como un arma
para hacer presión política a su favor
lo cierto es que tras las sanciones por
la invasión en ucrania rusia cortó el
gas a 6 países y redujo el suministro a
otros 6 por ejemplo los flujos hacia
alemania que es la mayor economía de la
unión europea se redujeron en dos
tercios la situación ha hecho que europa
se apresura a llenar los depósitos de
gas antes del invierno cuando esta
demanda aumenta las reservas de gas de
europa sólo están llenas en un 65%
frente al objetivo del 80 por ciento
para primero de noviembre conversamos
antes con santiago arroyo consultor
especializado de energía y petrolífero
sobre que puede hacer europa en este
escenario que es lo que debería estar
haciendo en europa ya lo seguro pues lo
tiene bien en claro que necesita
transición ar es decir la transición
energética es primordial sin embargo
también requieren volver a retomar
algunas algunas acciones que estaban
llevando a cabo en el pasado sobre todo
en el aspecto de energía nuclear hay que
recordar que ahorita yo creo que uno de
los países que tiene más en claro esto
es francia sobre todo por esta cuestión
de la recuperación de efe de estos de
estos activos que tienen sobre todo para
poder reforzar y refinanciar todo el
esquema de generación con energía
nuclear la energía nuclear por la
agencia energía de la agencia
internacional de energía la considera
una energía limpia porque porque no
genera con emisiones
de carbón y de azufre y contaminantes y
que son las que provocan el cambio en
esta crisis climática que vivimos y los
efectos invernadero entonces francia
tiene muy en claro esta parte e
inglaterra también polonia también está
está girando a esto jorge pero mientras
esta transición ocurre en europa el
invierno está a la vuelta de la esquina
empieza oficialmente el 21 de diciembre
pero el frío comienza desde el otoño un
par de meses antes y es que además del
frío europa enfrenta otro gran dilema
que es el de los precios los altos
precios de la energía y amenazan con
provocar una recesión en europa por la
inflación récord y el banco central
europeo- subió esta semana los tipos de
interés hay que tomar en cuenta que el
gas se utiliza en una serie de procesos
que la mayoría de personas nunca ve como
forjar acero para fabricar vehículos
hacer botellas de vidrio y pasteurizar
leche y queso europa necesitaría ahorrar
12 mil millones de metros cúbicos de gas
para este invierno la unión europea
pedirá a los estados miembros que
reduzcan voluntariamente su consumo de
gas en un 15% durante los próximos meses
aunque esta acción va a estar
a las acciones ciudadanas también italia
francia y la unión europea en general
buscan cerrar acuerdos con suministros
alternativos pero estas negociaciones
van más lento de lo esperado como será
el invierno ahí se lo preguntamos a
nuestro invitado
lastimosamente tendrían que empezar a
considerar
ser o dispensar más bien el
tema de las emisiones contaminantes base
carbón
tendría que pensar bastante de esa parte
digo tomar decisiones bastante difíciles
en torno a esta parte de la transición
energética quizás tengan que volver a
acomodar yo creo que es más fácil
acomodar o hacer un reacomodo de las
estrategias para la descarbonización
y aplazarlo 34 años más en lo que
resuelven en un mediano plazo todo este
tema con mayor infraestructura realmente
lo que se necesita es más
infraestructura yo creo que ya está muy
metido el tiempo para poder desarrollar
algo sobre todo en renovables que pueden
ayudar o mitigar jorge la gran paradoja
mientras europa también la falta de
suministro de gas rusia está recibiendo
dinero por los altos precios de la venta
de gas santiago y es que para darnos una
idea el aumento de los ingresos
energéticos de rusia en los últimos
cinco meses es tres veces superior a lo
que suele ganar exportando gas a europa
durante todo un invierno los ingresos de
rusia por petróleo y gas rondan los 95
mil millones de dólares según la agencia
internacional de energía según nuestro
invitado los precios seguirán moderados
pero con una tendencia al alza
la preocupación por la escasez del gas
sigue golpeando al euro muchas gracias
jorge por este reporte del mundo de la
economía a continuación en directo
américa el debate